[Musique]
bienvenue à l'intérieur de fifa 22 gameplay
hypermotion est le plus grand ajout au
gameplay de fifa 22.
propulsé par la technologie de haute promotion du football réel
est une
exclusivité de nouvelle génération qui révolutionne le
gameplay de football dans chaque match de chaque mode
combinant capture de match 11b11 avancée
et apprentissage automatique  pour la toute première fois, l'
hypermotion offre une foule de nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui améliorent l'
expérience de jeu de fifa 22 la
capture de match avancée 11v11 débloque
le mouvement authentique de toute l'équipe le plus grand
rafraîchissement d'animation de l'histoire de la fifa depuis des
années, nous avons capturé les
mouvements des joueurs individuels mais pour la première fois nous  'ai
utilisé des combinaisons xn pour la
capture de mouvement simultanée de 22 footballeurs professionnels
jouant à haute intensité
les données de chaque touche taclée et le
sprint inspire plus de 4 000 nouvelles
animations augmentant la réactivité
physique et l'intensité des joueurs et des
équipes lorsqu'ils se déplacent sur le terrain
[Applaudissements]
le gameplay de fifa 22 est rendu encore plus réel
par l'apprentissage automatique  En
traduisant 8,7 millions d'images de
données de capture de match en animation réactive,
notre algorithme de flux ml vous permet d'ajuster
votre foulée en temps réel comme le
font les pros avec une précision au premier contact lorsque vous vous
approchez du ballon
[Musique] L'
IA tactique rend les 22 joueurs plus intelligents
sur le terrain
avec jusqu'à six fois plus de décisions prises
par seconde, les attaquants sont désormais plus rapides à
réagir et plus intelligents avec leurs courses
tandis qu'une réécriture défensive permet aux équipes
d'agir comme une unité et de garder leur forme
hors du ballon
des animations à deux joueurs améliorées intensifient
la lutte pour le ballon  dans les airs,
ressentez la physique alors que les défenseurs et les
attaquants poussent, tirent et se bousculent avec plus de
réactivité et des résultats plus propres,
contrôlez-le comme le meilleur au monde avec
des animations à deux touches plus longues.
informé par la capture de match 11v11 avancée
ressentez le rythme du match avec de nouvelles
animations hors ballon
voyez l'émotion de t  football de niveau opérationnel alors que les
joueurs parlent et se
dirigent comme vous le voyez sur le terrain
et fifa 22 a des avancées encore plus fondamentales
un tout nouveau système de gardien de but rend votre
numéro un plus fiable entre les
poteaux
avec un arrêt de tir plus composé et
plus de personnalité qui se reproduit  les
différents styles de gardiens de classe mondiale
tandis que les données du monde réel apportent la vraie
physique de la balle dans le jeu pour la faire voler
et rebondir comme la vraie chose
et une fois que la balle est à vos pieds, le
sprint explosif vous donne plus de contrôle
sur le moment de libérer votre accélération
tout en dribblant  et en défense
parlant de plus de contrôle, de
nouvelles tactiques d'attaque vous permettent de choisir comment
votre équipe joue dans chaque moitié du
terrain
afin que vous puissiez créer votre groupe de football unique
[Applaudissements]
ressentez l'énergie de votre prochain grand match
avec des atmosphères immersives, un
éclairage dynamique et un  nouvelle équipe de commentateurs qui donne
vie au stade chaque
jour de match bien la scène est mise en place un excellent jeu
en service et un vibran  t atmosphère et
quand vous l'enterrez au fond du filet,
faites de plus grandes scènes avec un stade plein
de fans
après tout, c'est ce qu'est le jeu
fifa 22 propulsé par le football
[Musique]
vous